ماذا لو فوجئت بالارض تحتز تحت قدميك بقوه
وانت جالس في منزلك حاله من الرعب تنتابك
وتحتل صدرك ترتفع نسبه الادرينالين بجسمك
وتتسارعون نبضات قلبك هنا يتوقف عقلك عن
التفكير لتذهب بك قدماك نحو الشرفه دون ان
تشعر لتفاجئ بالابنيه حولك تتمايل يمينا
ويسارا ومنها ما ينهار ويسقط ويتحولوا الى
انقاب الناس تصرخ باعلى صوت راجين النجاه
القتلى يتساقطون الواحده والاخر يا الهي
ماذا يحدث هل هي نهايه العالم تدخل من
الشرفه مرعوبا من هول المنظر الذي شاهدته
ايعقل ان كل تلك الابنيه تنهار في نفس
الوقت انه زلزال مدمر بقوه ثمان او تسع
درجات الاخطار تحاول الهرب والنزول الى
الشارع باي شكل لانقاذ حياتك
تتساقط من حولك اذا وقعت احداها عليك فقد
ترضيك قتيلا تحاول الوصول الى الباب
لتصطدم بزحام السكان الشديد الكل يحاول
الهرب وانقاذ حياته تكدس دراهم امام
المصعد وعلى السلالم تضطر للرجوع وتدخل
منزلك مره اخرى فالنزول الى الشارع اصبح
شبه مستحيل ولكن ماذا افعل لا سبيل للعرب
والجدران والابنيه تتساقط كل ما هو مرتفع
في المنزل يسقط على الارض بسرعه مذهله
وسوره مروعه تضطر للاحتماء باي شيء ولكن
ماذا لو انهار العقار الذي انت بداخله هل
ستكون من الاحياء فالبقاء حيا تحت الانقاض
ليس مضمونا الامر مرعب يا عزيزي فما هي
افضل الطرق التي تقوم بها لتحمي نفسك عند
وقوع زلزال قوي وماذا تفعل لو ادى الامر
لان تصبح حيا تحت الانقاض وما هي الطريقه
العبقريه التي تحمي بها اليابان نفسها من
خطر الزلازل لتعرف اجابه كل تلك الاسئله
عليك مشاهده دقائق الفيديو القادم
اخطاء تزيد الخطر اخطاء عديده يقوم بها
اغلب الناس عند وقوع زلزال منها انهم
يسرعون للهرب خارج منازلهم او الاتجاه نحو
الشرفات وان كانوا في الخارج فهم يحاولون
الاحتماء بالانفاق او الجسور وهذا ما
يفاقم الازمه ويزيد الخطر وبعد الزلزال
المدمر الذي شهدته تركيا وسوريا اصبح
السؤال الذي يفرض نفسه على اذهاننا كيف
اتصرف وقت وقوع زلزال طرق الحمايه بالمنزل
يقول الخبراء انه اذا داهمك زلزال وكنت في
المنزل فاهم شيء هو ان تحافظ على هدوء
اعصابك ولا تقترب من الشرفات او المخارج
ولا تسرع نحو الباب من اجل الهرب وابتعد
تماما عن الاجهزه الكهربائيه واغلق كل
مصادر الطاقه الموجوده بمنزلك قدر الامكان
ابتعد عن كل الاماكن التي بها رفوف مرتفعه
او اي اشياء معلقه لان كل هذا قد ينهار
فوق راسك اذهب الى مكان امن بالمنزل وانزل
تحت الفراش او اي جسم كبير وصلب للاحتماء
به وفي حال انهيار العقار الذي تسكن فيه
وكنت من الاحياء تحت الانقاض فحاول الحفاظ
على هدوءك وابحث عن اي جسم معدني كبير ثم
حاول اخراجه بيدك واطرق به بقوه على
الركام وذلك للفت انتباه فرق الانقاذ
والذين سيسرعون لانقاذك انت ومن معك ولكن
ماذا لو كنت بالخارج
طرق الحمايه بالخارج اذا وقع زلزال وانت
خارج المنزل فابتعد تماما عن المباني
والاعمده الكهربائيه اياك ان تلمس اي سلك
كهربائي فقط تصاب بازمه قلبيه في الحال بل
حاول ان تقف في مكان امن ولا تتحرك حتى
تنتهي الهزه الارضيه وان كنت تقود سياره
فلا تهرع الى الجسور او الانفاق فكل هذا
قد ينهار بفعل الزلزال بل عليك ان تقف
بالسياره في منطقه نائيه او تبتعد بها عن
اماكن العقارات قدر الامكان ولا تخرج من
سيارتك حتى تتاكد من ان الهزه الارضيه قد
انتهت تماما وزال الخطر الامر يبدو لك غير
منطقي فعقل الانسان غالبا ما يتوقف عن
التفكير بشكل صحيح عند حدوث الكاذب ولذلك
فان اول نصيحه قالها الخبراء كانت ان تحول
الحفاظ على هدوء اعصابك قدر الامكان ولكن
ماذا لو كنت من سكان المدن الساحليه
والذين هم اكثر عرضه لموجات تسونامي المدم
اخطار المدن الساحليه اذا كان مركز
الزلزال هو قاع البحر فغالبا ما يتبعه
موجات تسونامي مدمره نتيجه تحرك القشره
الارضيه وهنا تكمل الخطوره التي تواجهها
المدن الساحليه لذلك ينصح الخبراء بان يتم
بناء العقارات والمنازل بتلك المدن بالطرق
المقاومه للزلازل وموجات تسونامي وهي احدى
طرق البناء المتبعه من القرن الماضي خصوصا
في الدول التي تقع ضمن احزمه الزلازل وتعد
اشهرها دوله اليابان والتي اتخذت عده
اجراءات احترازيه من القرن الماضي للوقايه
من اخطار الزلازل فكيف تحمي اليابان نفسها
من تلك الاخطار
ابنيه تتراقص دون اضرار
تعد اليابان من اكثر الدول عرضه للزلازل
والدمار فهي تواجه اكثر من 1500 زلزال
سنويا ولكن اذا ذهبت الى هناك الان وحدث
زلزال قوي فسوف تفاجا بالابنيه الشاهقه
تتراقص امامك دون ان يحدث لها اي ضرر
كانها مصنوعه من المطاط ولا احد من السكان
يهرب منها او يحاول النزول الى الشارع
الكل في مكانه ورغم قوه الزلزال ليس هناك
اضرار تذكر ولا ابنيه تنهار الا لو كانت
درجه الزلزال تفوق حدود العقل كتسع درجات
مثلا على مقياس ريختار وحتى في هذه الحاله
لن تكون الاضرار بسبب الزلزال نفسه وانما
بفعل موجات تسونامي التي تتبع الزلزال
فماذا فعلت اليابان
التغلب على الزلازل
منذ عقود مضت هرعت اليابان لايجاد حل جذري
لكارثه الزلازل التي تواجهها سنويا والتي
تخلف ورائها الاف الضحايا وانهيار عشره
الالاف من المباني فسبقت اليابان كل الدول
العالم في استحداث طريقه علميه معقده في
البناء طورها العلماء على مدى عشرات
السنين مثل فصل جسم البناء عن الارض
بقاعدات مرنه جدا وتم تطويرها هذه الطريقه
من نظام امتصاص الصدمات في السيارات ولكن
باستخدام مواد وتركيبات هندسيه اكثر
تعقيدا ثم يقومون بتصميم نظام معقد جدا
لشبكه المياه يضمن توصيل المياه للشقق
بشكل اكثر سلاسه وعدم تسرب المياه بايه
طريقه واضعاف اساسات المبنى وتلك الطريقه
تجعل المبنى مهما كان ارتفاعه اكثر
استقرارا على الارض وقت حدوث الهزه
الارضيه ستجد المبنى يتميز يمينا ويسارا
ولكنه لا ينهار وينتهي الزلزال بسلام دون
اضرار تذكر
مباني لالف سنه الطريقه التي استحدثتها
اليابان كانت معجزه هندسيه بكل المقاييس
ففي الوقت الذي تتحلل او تنهار فيه كل
ابنيه العالم خلال مئه عام على الاكثر
بفعل الامطار والظواهر الطبيعيه الاخرى
ضمنت الطريقه اليابانيه وقوف المباني
الشاهقه شامخه لمده 1000 عام على الاقل
وفي ظل كل تلك الكوارث الطبيعيه التي
تتعرض لها اليابان سنويا لعلك ستقول ما
دام الامر كذلك فلماذا وقع اكثر من 15 الف
قتيل ضحيه زلزال الذي ضرب اليابان عام
ليسوا ضحايا الزلزال
دعني اقول لك ان هذا العدد الضخم من
الضحايا لم يكن ناتجا عن الزلزال نفسه
فالزلزال الذي ضرب جزيره هونشيو اليابانيه
عام 2011 كان بقوه تسعه رختار اي اقوى من
الزلزال الذي ضرب تركيا وسوريا ثلاث مرات
وبلغت قوته التدميريه لدرجه انه اثر على
سرعه الارض كلها ورغم ذلك لم يخلف هذا
الزلزال وراءه ضحايا بشريه اكثر من خمسين
شخصا فقط ولم تحدث اي اضرار بالمباني
بينما وقع الاف الضحايا بفعل الكوارث
الاخرى التي احدثتها تلك الهزه الارضيه
فقوه هذه الزلزال احدثت ارتفاعا كبيرا في
منسوب مياه البحر ادى لهجوم موجات تسونامي
مدمره بطول 12 مترا اي ما يعادل طول ثلاث
طوابق وادى الامر الى انصهار مفاعل
فوكوشيما النووي لتشهد اليابان في ذات
الوقت اكبر كارثه نوويه حدثت في القرن 21
لذا فالاف الاشخاص الذين قتلوا كانوا
ضحايا لموجات تسونامي مرع والكارثه
النوويه التي حدثت في فعل الزلزال فهل
صمتت اليابان بعد خطر تسونامي
التغلب على تسونامي لم تقف اليابان مكتوفه
الايدي امام خطر تسونامي فقامت بتطوير
جهاز انذار مبكر للتحذير من موجات تسونامي
قادمه كما طورت وسائل نقل على اعلى مستوى
تستطيع من خلالها اجلاء ملايين الاشخاص من
المدينه خلال ساعه واحده فقط والان هل ترى
ان من الممكن الاستفاده من الطريقه
اليابانيه لتفادي اخطار الزلازل